[Music]
ding-ding-ding-ding welcome back to the
julienne podcast this week we're banging
on things he's fine he's just curious
this episode is brought to you by stitch
fix guys is shopping for clothes a
hassle rhetorical question it is a
hassle I know firsthand because I'm a
human being who has shopped for clothes
it sucks stitch fix is here to solve
that problem basically it is a service
where a personal stylist will handpick
items and send it right to your door and
all you got to do is go on their website
and fill out some questions answer some
style questions and they hook you up it
is awesome their styling fees only
twenty dollars which is applied toward
anything you keep from your shipment so
get started right now when you go to
stitch fix calm slash turn and Julien
you'll get an extra twenty five percent
off when you keep all the items in your
box check it out super cool service
I actually just submitted for my first
box it didn't get here in time for this
episode it's coming next week what could
be posted I wanna see what you got me
I'm interested I don't know what they
sent me but hopefully it's good
also guys honey book if you were a
graphic designer or a photographer a
honey book is helping you spend less
time with the business and boring side
of the of your business and leaving you
with more time to spend on the creative
which is what you want to do right you
don't no one wants to deal with a
paperwork in the business so honey book
is here to help you with that payment is
flexible use code Jenna Julian you get
50% off monthly or annually that's 20
hours a month or $200 a whole year of
organization of your calendar management
tools branding brochures proposals
contracts all the stuff you don't want
to deal with honey book does it for you
go - honey book calm and use promo code
Jenna Julian and get started
more on that later Thank You sponsors
well let's just jump into her let's jump
into it that was so funny somebody
tweeted let's just jump it's like one of
my favorite memes just cross out into it
well we're gonna jump into this one it's
a trend that's been going around on
YouTube they're fun to watch I like them
I have seen them I haven't either
admittedly not watched any of them but I
can kind of get the gist it's a pretty
funny idea basically you ask your
audience what their assumptions of you
are and then you go over them and read
them yeah so that's what we're gonna do
it we have a wallet rollin some y'all
are serious there's a good mix there's a
good mix of trolls going right for the
jugular yeah well I guess we should just
get it right it is we I tweeted it out
we did long Instagram basically on
Instagram you can do it so anonymously
so people so it's not public what people
are writing hmm so that's why Instagram
was preferred but we did a few on
Twitter anyway so we have Twitter
Instagram we have a bunch
you ready yeah gray says y'all are
definitely just friends and are finally
starting to tell the truth well you are
my friends not friends and that is the
very funny assumption especially since
last week on the podcast and in my video
that that's when the joke started the
joke is only like what week old that
we're just friends
yes my friends own dude my video yeah
friends on hard for six years of being
in a relationship definitely yeah nope
we're not friends it's just a joke it'll
be gone by next week don't worry there
will be something else to replace it Rai
Rai says you plan on slowly retreating
from society and living in a tropical
paradise of your own making
honestly that's like yeah I mean that
sounds nice
it's kind of your dream you've you've
said that's your dream for a while to go
live on a farm somewhere in the middle
of nowhere yeah it wouldn't it probably
wouldn't be a tropical paradise it would
be uh somewhere where I can chill and
have a lot of animals nothing against
tropical paradises but no everything
against truck tropical paradises I don't
know you know I'm from like upstate New
York I feel like if I were to ever be
like okay I'm gonna go be a recluse for
the rest of my life it would probably be
somewhere in the United States that you
know was just seasons
I'm Way too but I feel like I'm too
easily bored
to be completely isolated from other
people completely like oh you wouldn't
be isolate from other people but so like
in this scenario I do society as like
you're no longer on the internet or like
a public
yesin so that's like a no you sort of
just go I've always thought about this
though because like in Breaking Bad they
have this this guy spoiler alert they
have this guy getting spoiled who's a
vacuum cleaner salesman but basically
what he does is he wipes your identity
and gives you a new one and he sends you
somewhere completely off the grid well
like witness protection yeah but it's
like it's Underground witness protection
to where the government's not involved
it's just their party but I've thought
about that like what would that be
that's really interesting to think about
what have you got have you got a new
idea
Jane Armstrong and you live in Wisconsin
and you have to go there and change the
way you look a little bit and not really
talk to anyone for a while and stay at
the [ __ ] off the internet and you're a
different person like that's a crazy
thought yeah think about so no no
there's no actual plans to do it but
like I don't know for in many many many
years it's like that was a thing that
happened that wouldn't be so bad to me
that wouldn't I feel like there are
worse end games than that right it's
pretty straight forward and game yeah
like if [ __ ] it's the family being just
like a regular person yeah but like far
removed farmer and maybe under a
different name
yeah but there's plenty people in this
country the
of their lives that way and are so happy
and fulfilled mm-hmm and I think that's
really beautiful so I agree I don't I
think it would happen much slower than
anyone would ever care about yeah we
just bought a house yeah I'd be like
older and no one would give a [ __ ] yeah
endgame yeah no one gives a [ __ ] always
give a [ __ ] friend about you friend
friends best friends Emma says Julian
showers in a wet suit oh my god that's
really funny
that's patrol I'm worn a wet suit
probably like three times in my life
twice when I tried surfing and just
wasn't for me and then a third I think
when I was wakeboarding maybe once that
is one of the most miserable things to
get in and out of I don't know if you've
ever done in a worn one oh my god
surfers who do it every morning
who get inside mostly getting out of it
mmm putting it on it's not that bad
getting out of it it's like wet it's
cold it's tight everywhere and you have
to you really have to like get your app
get your way out of it with your
shoulders like that was my nightmare
yeah you're not very flexible in use my
shoulders are pretty tight they're not
flexible so sometimes I'll struggle to
get like a jacket off so I've been
witnessed so that many toes I will
assure you I do not shower in a wetsuit
what's the point of showering if you're
waiting I don't know to protect yourself
clean well as long as the wetsuits clean
you're clean supposedly okay is that a
thing that but that's not a thing no one
actually does that at home I mean if
you're showering on the beach after
surfing yeah shower and wetsuit but even
then no you don't sour in a wits was
that thing was on shark tank where it's
like a shower buddy yeah it's pretty
cool it was cool it's they were
comparing it to a garbage bag we like
loop it over your head and it's like a
portable little you can get undressed
and wash yourself it's kind of cool
yeah that's pretty dope yeah
I don't surf or go out in public so it's
not for me but it's cool okay Jenna you
have an innate urge to mother any living
thing from soupy sayin probably I'm
trying I'm trying to think of something
that I haven't had the urge to like care
for if it comes my way then yeah but
like if it's a spider no I don't have an
any urge to mother a spider you know
okay so sans insects yep ah well some
insects are like super cool and I'm like
actually down with but most of them are
not your house pests or their pets you
they're pests right like you're you
don't want them in the house cockroach
yeah if I was like okay you Julian all
the bugs that are here are now my babies
like that's not safe for the dogs this
sa for us that's not a good idea but
yeah you know anything that comes my way
like any dog that shows up here which
happens more than you have that instinct
hardcore plants yeah a bark or any
mammal absolutely some reptiles some
insects like have you seen the praying
mantis people on YouTube that have them
as pets
they're like so cool no I have not
fallen down the praying mantis people
holy well one of my favorite video is
called mantis squad and they're all just
standing there like with their arms up
and they're just like doing this what a
cool mannerism for an insect to have
they're amazing and we see them outside
around us sometimes and they are just
like they're really cool so stunning
like yeah if if I found a injured
praying mantis yeah I would try and take
care of it yeah because he's like a he's
a special insect you know hmm
we also went to animal tracks that like
Animal Farm Sanctuary place where they
care for animals that like people
improperly tried to have his pets and we
learned about what was the animal that
Kermit dragged out of the bush that one
time possum awesome we learned about
possums we got to meet one and we
learned that they were like actually
really not that like bad and
disease they don't carry diseases like a
lot of people think well I mean if it
bit your dog you probably want to take
them to go get like people's images baby
shot of one of those is just like
foaming at the mouth and crazy and like
you know they're just like any other
animal like when I was sitting outside
the other night and a raccoon walked up
to me and I just looked at me you can't
be here
come come don't they don't want to like
attack you yeah if they were rabid or
something you'd be able to tell if
they're sick you didn't see him during
the daytime or whatever but ya know if
if I thought any mammal if I found them
injured I would try and do something
because it's it's a mammal you're like
you know you can have a little
connection or understanding like a furry
small thing mm-hmm
but reptiles or birds like when I was
younger we used to find unsaved a lot of
birds that had you know flown into stuff
and my dad would feed him pushed up cat
food and we try and help him learn how
to fly but that bird that flew into our
house during our stream yeah if that
bird hadn't gotten out and he was hurt I
would have put him in a bottle we've
done that before where I found an
injured bird and I'll put him in a box
Birds I feel like I can try and help a
lizard or something I can try and help
but like an insect II analyst it was a
big one like a praying mantis or
something I'd probably be like look fin
if you got venom in there I don't know
if this is gonna work out I think it's
gonna work out fair enough
Natalie says I assumed that I assumed
that Julian still hasn't fixed the
switch to the fireplace yet and that
Julian is really super awkward in person
and tries to cover it up and just ends a
vacuum more awkward well let me just the
first part of this you're right okay
I spent many many hours on that
fireplace and it ended up with me
realizing that I was in over my head on
like a technical standpoint electrical
stuff well like yeah electrician I
thought I was like honestly I was this
close the problem was I wasn't I'm gonna
bore you guys now since you asked about
it I wasn't getting enough power to the
Wi-Fi switcher that as much as it needed
so they
tically the normal light switch that
just says on and off it only requires a
base amount of power not that much but
if you have a Wi-Fi signal in the switch
it needs more power and I wasn't getting
it so I messed around with the wires and
at one point I gave too much power and
it would short the the fuse so I got
like way too high power way too little
power and then I just found myself in a
bind where I was like I'm gonna ruin
something so I need to just stop so I
put it on the old switch and I I tabled
that project for later I am incredibly
awkward in person I wouldn't say I'm
like painfully awkward like like I think
I've got I'm pretty good at being not
totally crazy in social situations even
if I'm uncomfortable I'm able to kind of
like small talk and you know make people
feel comfortable especially after you
know we go to we've over the years we've
been on YouTube we've spent a lot of
times doing meet-and-greets and I think
you get you get a little bit better each
time at like talking to people
mmm-hmm but I would still say I'm
awkward I don't know yeah
well it is a strange interaction when
people know everything about you and you
don't know anything about them yeah for
sure but I wouldn't call you awkward by
any means
thanks person yeah friend friend
actually I'm your friend volume means
move on well you cannot if you do that
you're not talking into the mic that's
why I'm so sorry so either put it close
to your mouth or raise the volume you
choose yeah dig dink know you can move
Eevee tweeted I assume that Jillian
blows his nose on tissues and leaves
them everywhere I'm at Jenna where's her
Leisure Suit three times a week uh no
you don't even do that when you're sick
no I don't do that I I understand why
she might assume that no is the paper
towel issue yeah yeah sometimes when I'm
in the kitchen and I'm I'm in a groove
as some artists or chefs would would say
you use the paper towel quickly and
leave it somewhere and after a while
there's a bunch of
with towels on the counter how did those
get there I don't know but I don't blow
my nose and leave tissues ever that's
kind of gross no I feel like you
wouldn't put up with that
I wouldn't put up with that no no no
like I can understand if someone's
really sake and like you're laying on
the couch and you have like a little
pile of tissues going or something like
it's a short-term thing yeah but like
I've never even seen you do that yeah I
also don't blow my nose like in front of
people I find that to be really
uncomfortable like I'll go to the
bathroom to blow my nose or like you
know some people will just like do it
really loud in front of people and
they're finally and they put it in their
pocket like I always see that I'm like
to him that's like a brave like you know
I always need to like just be on my own
I'm the same way yeah I don't have that
what about the Leisure Suit three times
a week no no no it's very comfortable
but like it needs to go in the wash it's
just like wear it and it's like I'll get
too hot you know yeah like if I like to
be under a blanket sometimes so like if
I'm just like where I can't like have
long sleeves and long pants and like be
under play h-how'd be pretty cold
you have worked out and I thought before
oh yeah which is a sight to see because
you were leisure in under a barbell with
a hundred thirty-five pounds on it that
was very confusing to see but it's
badass I don't wear it that much Cassie
dig I assume Kermit cries in the middle
of the night accurate he cries are you
guys bought a lot you guys know that if
you think of a time of day hate crimes
during it or night go get up well
sometimes he won't cry right away so
like if he's really thirsty in the
middle of the night we leave water out
on the ground for the dogs he'll get up
and he'll start digging at the dish like
moving it around pushing it around the
room and if I don't get up where Julian
doesn't get up he'll just look at you go
yeah he'll get on to the bed he perches
up like remember that snapshot the one
that turned into him he was like when he
climbs up higher you guys louder he does
that because he finds perch points where
he can he knows you see and hear him and
then he'll cry yes
so I wake up to him crying often I would
say more and more morning morning
morning morning yeah I wake up to him
crying more mornings than I do to him
not crying
yeah but middle of the night he's not a
child it's only if he's thirsty or like
really has to go to the bathroom when
he's been sick a couple times or before
he got diagnosed with Cushing's he kept
me up so many nights because it was just
so I felt horrible for him and we
couldn't figure out what was going on
yeah and he felt like he was hungry he
felt like he was thirsty and he would
like ordered the door like he needed to
go out and I would just you know I would
get 20 minutes of sleep and then he'd be
screaming at me but since he got
diagnosed and he's on medication now for
a while there's no screaming in the
middle of the night but yeah there was a
block of time in there when I just
wasn't getting any sleep and I felt so
bad for him yeah but now it's just if
he's thirsty or has to really go potty
for some reason or if he's bored if we
if we went to bed really late because of
a stream and we're sleeping till like
noon he'll get up at like 11:00 and be
like [ __ ] yeah scarfie I scare you
I assume that you both are very much
enjoying all of the content you're
putting out on your channels right now
and on Twitch well two or three years
ago it might have felt a bit more forced
interesting yeah I mean it's like it's
hindsight at this point so yeah in
hindsight I'd say I enjoy the content
that we make now more but at the time I
would have said I make the content now I
like it now more than I did the repple
years ago so I think it's 20/20
hindsight but it's not that it wasn't
authentic at the time or anything and it
was also YouTube was a different
landscape you know and our podcast was
different our twitch stream was
different things different and it's a
reflection of who you are now in time
you know yeah I like that outlook I
think that's good I mean I think at any
point I neither of us have ever really
made content that wasn't true to us it
was just you change as you grow up
and as you also change in your lifespan
online not just your life and I feel
like that's shown a lot and I think
we're at a point where we're really
lucky in a lot of ways like with twitch
and the time we spend streaming like
it's become a really awesome outlet and
like platform for us to capitalize our
the style of fun we like to have in the
content that gets made from it and I
think we're it's like the product of a
lot of things it's not just like we
prefer our content now than it was five
years ago it's like a lot of things
happened for this to happen yeah so
shouts out Marissa she compiled a whole
bunch of these
and then also sent a screen shot of her
assumptions about us for me
Candice writes Julie intends to get up
before Jenna in the morning that's true
true
I mean mainly because I trained you
Jitsu in the morning I have a hard time
falling asleep at night too you do I'm
notoriously asleep before always every
single and waking up before you mm-hmm
grace Dobler wrote six times
Yeller fit as hell Thank You grace we
try I mean we're I'm by no means in the
best shape I've ever been in but we just
tried it well I feel like we work out a
lot and then we get a lot of exercise
and we do really good at that but yeah
we also enjoy eating food and rally
swigging yeah and like obviously we
could both be in better shape or I have
our diets
you know cleaner whatever but I'm also
like I'm 32 year old lady and I'm just
having a good time as long as I'm
healthy I'm happy you know yeah so I
wouldn't say we're fit is help but we do
like to lift heavy weights we like to
literally just a lot of jiu-jitsu I do
not do Jitsu at all it is not the sport
for me there was a bunch of assumptions
that I didn't screen John them but they
were like Jenna's secretly better than
Julianne at jujitsu my god just never
trains but it's innately better than
ever I can promise you I'm even worse
than you've ever seen in any of it
you love it no you literally have like a
bump on your eye today from jiu-jitsu
come home and it'll just have like bumps
and bruises all over him that doesn't
look like fun it's a little shiny it's a
fun it's a it's a reminder of how much
fun I had today Oh Janie writes you both
are getting sick of YouTube and would
consider doing twitch full-time I don't
think that's gonna happen not for me at
least I'll speak for myself hmm yeah I
would I would agree with you I I I get
why you would write that because we
spend a lot of time on Twitter you know
at least for me I spend much less time
making YouTube videos than I once did
you know I was once doing five days a
week and now I'm doing one maybe two but
I think it's a reflection of not
preferring one platform to the other but
deciding how you want to spend your time
between two platforms which is something
that like twitch was never that for us
it was always like a side project that
we treated like a side project and now
we're just doing a lot more of it yeah
well we started playing a lot more games
and we started having a lot of fun and a
lot of our friends started playing the
community of people we play with has
grown so much and it's really really
special it's really fun but I don't
think there's ever a bone in my body
that's like I my end date for YouTube is
X or it's coming or it exists you know I
don't really have that in my mind I have
that in my mind just as much as I have
my end date for being on the Internet
yeah you know yeah I don't think that's
gonna happen I still very much enjoy the
platform of YouTube and I mean I as well
as anybody else that's been creating
content for a while and that can be any
amount of time yeah you do hit tons of
creative walls and sort of fatigue at
different levels and I think that's sort
of a normal I think you know I get tired
of it sometimes I anything you know you
can't do something for ten years and not
have like your ups and downs with it but
I'm still very much in love with and
enamored with YouTube as a platform I
just think it's [ __ ] spectacular and
this the stuff that you can find on
there and the people you can find on
there like it is just so amazing and for
all of its downfalls and like not great
stuff I think it's just like a wonderful
place for learning and sharing and
there's nothing else like it I have no
intention of leaving it for anything you
know 100 percent I wouldn't be like oh
I'm I'm no longer on YouTube I'm gonna
be on Twitch now yeah you know cuz it's
just not the same type of stuff your
interaction yeah that's why they they to
me they either need to coexist or like I
wouldn't be on the Internet you know
even if whenever you know the ratio of
time you spent fluctuates that's yeah
yeah I still love YouTube I watch
YouTube as as much or more than anything
else and yeah yeah I I think personally
like being able to upload videos to
YouTube and have people watch them and
then you also watch other people's
videos is such a simple concept but for
me it's helped me so much like discover
a huge passion of mine which is like
making videos I'm like filming and doing
stuff with cameras I never really would
have figured that out for myself had it
not been for an outlet like YouTube to
where I could share it and interact with
people who are watching it so I think
it's like you said there's a lot there's
nothing perfect about it but there's a
lot of really special things that still
exist about YouTube and well yeah and a
lot of some of its getting weird you
know like the whole space is getting a
little weird
yeah and I think that's normal when
there's money to be made on any platform
stuff starts to get a little strange but
when I sit down and watch all the plant
videos that I like like literally
anything that you want to learn about is
on YouTube in a way for you to
understand so you can always teach
yourself you can always pick up anything
that you'd like to learn which is one of
the most powerful and amazing tools
that's happened in my lifetime that I
can think of and like when I sit down
and I watch the the plant youtubers that
I really like or you know whatever I'm
super into at the moment mint its quad
mentis is sway back and forth like I
think about how sometimes that person
you watch a channel for a long time and
you can tell they're sort of like okay
there's only so many [ __ ] videos I
can make about plants you know what
should I do
what else do you want like this is weird
but even when I get
- those videos I'm like I just
appreciated that you uploaded like I
appreciated that you shared something
and I know that you're probably tired
but like I like this video and I'm glad
that you you know did that you know I
mean 100 percent so like I don't think
there's any part of me that would ever
really get over that because the world
is always changing and there's always
gonna be new things to learn yeah you
know and even if I'm posting something
that I in my world and brain think like
well nobody cares and nobody wants to
see it like if you do just share there
are people just like that you know they
just want to see it it's like a moment
of comfort or distraction or learning or
whatever it is yeah it's really cool
so I don't think I'd like to give that
part of my life up yeah I remember like
five years ago we were in Australia and
we were with part of write Ryan he is
production company rhpc and Greg was
there we got like a party and we were
hanging out with them and I was talking
to Greg about editing because I was just
like starting to edit at the time and he
had already been going strong for a
number of years doing the effects and
the edits for Ryan and I was just like
interested to talk to him about it
because it was like talking shop you
know and I remember he told me something
that like for me it's just like clicked
in my head and we were talking about
like After Effects and how he learned it
and he was literally just like one day I
decided that I was gonna sit down and
teach myself because of YouTube and like
anything you want to learn is somewhere
and so I did it and I and I remember
thinking like holy [ __ ] like it's really
that simple yeah it's like up to you in
this day and age what you want to
accomplish what skills you want to you
know learn and provide yourself and your
teammates or your partners with and Ivy
I feel like that's kind of stuck with me
because I've used in a lot of ways and
to to help myself and my point is is
that YouTube is like it's the it's the
holy mecca for knowledge or any sort of
interest or hobby you might have yeah
aside from like Wikipedia or Google but
like in a video in the video form is
like so much different I mean reading a
manual I would say the majority of the
things I've gone out of my way to learn
how to do like a specific skill or
something
that has been through YouTube where in
the past you know I would have to go I
don't know find a book on it you know
your library yes or even like a paywall
like I remember lynda.com remember Linda
ah good to pay for the instructional
video exactly how was it that was the
thing hmm yeah but I mean especially
yeah no that's cool YouTube's cool yeah
and especially if you're an artistic
minded person and you don't want to deal
with like the business side of things
well that's not YouTube that's funny
block Julian Julian book is a website
where you can have all-in-one business
management tools provided to you if you
are the artistic person like a graphic
designer or an editor or a photographer
if you want your work to be your work
and the business work to be someone
else's work honey book is for you okay
it helps you spend more time running
your business on the creative side and
less time running your business on the
boring paperwork business side they
basically provide all sorts of tools
with calendar management custom branded
brochures for your clients your website
your contracts even proposals and you
can have you can even get a signatures
generate invoices and get paid faster
all within one online system that is
honey book and what's great is the
payment is flexible so if you use our
code generally and get 50% off monthly
if you want to sign up monthly or you
get if you want to do it on an annual
basis as well that's fifty percent off
for the first year of honey book with
promo code generally so this is not a
small thing that no one uses over
seventy five thousand photographers
designers event professionals and other
solo entrepreneurs that I'm sure many of
you guys are that have signed up with
honey book and they've saved hundreds
while doing it
I can't tell you the first time we had
any sort of help specifically with like
the podcast and I wasn't having to do
all the business side of things all the
contracts all the emailing is this huge
relief that I could finally just like
focus my energy on the part of it that
made me want to start in the first place
so honey book is really helping people
do that and they can help you too so
click the link down below and get
started use code Jen and Julian when you
go to honey book comets HOA and a YB oh
okay
really really cool service they have and
then when you want to look your best and
you don't want to go to the store or
stitch fix is the answer for you there
okay if you think about maybe changing
up your style and you're like yeah I
should wear more of this type of thing
or I should dress more professional or
not or less professional more sporty
whatever stitch fix is there to help you
so you don't have to spend an hour in a
dressing room going back and forth
getting different sizes and then leaving
them all with nothing because you're so
annoyed the worst I've been there many
times stitch fix allows you to go online
on to stitch fix calm slash pendulum and
you basically answer a bunch of
questions they give you they give you
sample clothing it's really cool right
like what they're good would you wear
this yes or no and then they would say
okay which of these two shirts would you
wear and then okay yeah this one okay
well what about this tie or you know I
mean so they would take you through this
whole process it's actually really nice
it's kind of fun it feels like a game
and after they collect all that data you
get assigned a personal stylist that
will handpick items based on your style
choices and it's really cool because
then it just arrives at your door that's
it
let's go them all you have to find
parking you have to try anything on of
course if it doesn't fit or if you're
not happy with it exchanges and returns
are always free so you take what you
love out of the box and you can return
the rest you don't have to keep
everything that you get in the shipment
and there's no subscription required you
can sign up to receive scheduled
shipments or get your fix whenever you
want if you want it right now and then
in another six months there's a wedding
you're going to or you want it then
whatever and the styling fee for stitch
fix is only twenty dollars which is
applied toward anything you keep in your
shipment so right now if you had a
stitch fix that's STI TCH fi XCOM slash
gym and Julian you get an extra twenty
five percent off when you keep all the
items in your box check it out super
cool service would ten out of ten
recommend thank you sponsor thank-you
sponsors okay this this next one is a
doozy X
rights you have really quiet sex so that
you don't freak out the dogs oh my god
not okay no no no no well you know
profit since we're just friends
inappropriate we are just friends this
you've made this incredibly awkward for
us completely platonic friends what kind
of question is this
is that a question you had asked any
anyone who has dogs oh boy oh boy
marble marble what do you think of this
question oh we should move on okay let's
move on
Julian's favorite mod is Marissa and he
adopted Busch I would love to adopt
Jenny loves but I love him so much
well I talk about him do it Julian just
like when we're hanging out I'll let go
on his Twitter Bush is like my escape
from the internet like I'll go on Bush's
Twitter like his YouTube to like laughs
and like you know forget about your day
or whatever move out he just like I [ __ ]
no one on this planet loves karma as
much as Bush and I love karma true I've
never met someone who loves karma as
much as you into least and he's just
like across the world like we just are
connected via our souls and our love for
that dog not that I know so many of you
love Kermit and you love him so much but
it's just a different level he like
knows Kermit and he's never met Carmen I
know it's it's it's pretty special my
favorite mod I don't have a favorite mod
I love all of them twitch mods equally
the I would say though Marissa has been
heavily involved from a very early start
point on twitch and has stayed
incredibly involved to the point where
you know I would credit her with us
growing a lot on twitch and when you
have a good team of moderators your own
yeah I would say like you your twitch
channel is only as good as your team of
moderators so if they're good and they
make good decisions and help you and
have your back welcome and make people
they make new new viewers feel welcome
and it's a safe place I mean it's oh
that's a hard job that people volunteer
decision
it's like you know when you sign on to
twitch and you're like this is exciting
I don't know how to use this platform
like any platform and you go and people
are alive so you write in the chat
you're like no hey how are you and then
someone greets you and they're like hey
yes like usually yeah no one says
anything back to you and the person
who's live-streaming probably doesn't
see it how many viewers yeah and you're
like okay sick what's that for yeah you
know no it's it's totally totally I have
I mean I have that same like anxiety
about that happening myself if I go into
a chatham like knowing it acknowledges
me or whatever so like that's a big
reason why we love Marissa and the rest
our team of mods like they're all
incredible so yeah this sure if it says
Julianne edits Jenna's videos oh not
true not true not true I'll occasionally
you know help with a trick or two in
post but no she added sir videos and I
ate at mine I yes the hours and lines on
my face will tell you how I don't know
if I've said this before but she taught
me Final Cut Pro I didn't know if I
don't cut pro until Jenna taught me it I
was I was very elementary I used a
little bit of Adobe in college and then
a little bit of Final Cut 7 growing up
because that's what my dad used but I
liked when I came to editing I was
useless and then she taught me Final Cut
Pro so I got the Royal Treatment from
one of the best out there and the
editing arena thank you sounds like you
spoke into his marble have some protein
hey no I wouldn't say that I'm like a
particularly gifted editing but yeah I
did I taught you how to use it because
you were using something else and I was
like oh my god what are you doing like
just use this and you're like using what
my school made me use yeah but I mean
you're very easy to teach in anything
because you're always very willing to
learn and like it's just easy to teach
you stuff so it didn't take you very
long obviously because anyone that's
most people have taught themselves don't
cut pro
yeah except for whatever people go into
the Apple Store and you know take those
classes I know they exist yeah I think
most people have taught themselves how
to edit it's not outrageously
complicated but yeah Jimmy writes
Julianne with an a ramps up his Aires
for the camera um yes and no right like
so I would agree with yes I know yes I
know anyone who has any sort of persona
or attitude or any sort of personality
traits that are very distinguishable for
their online persona or their online
presence I would say is amplified when
the cameras on yeah for most people like
almost all people so like yes in that
sense but at the same time I don't
really act differently i don't make
different choices I would say yes and no
in that some of your Aires is like
obviously the couple of times when you
like taking knives out of the knife
block and done the floss dance with them
like that's not stuff that you're just
like doing when we're hanging out
although a little bit like honestly you
do a lot of crazy stuff when we're alone
and there's no cameras on obviously it's
you're just in Aires but it's more of
just like the spontaneous making
decisions like being like once you get
in that mood you're like unstoppable
like control is different like I think
you would do something different on
camera like cut and I cut an onion with
a hammer like but now I'm thinking about
it like you do that stuff to meet
constant I just do it more I do it more
scheduled yeah it's on camera in the
video I'm doing more of it in a row
speaking of which not this week for us
but this week for you guys which is next
week for us you know it that way yes
Aries Susan it's [ __ ] every season I
think it's Wednesday I think it's the
21st oh god what a day for Aries season
the vegan yeah I mean if yeah that
doesn't surprise anyone right what all
right
Cassidy writes Jenna will profusely
apologize for anything if she's wrong
Julianne will take it to the grave wait
so does that mean I don't apologize I
apologize but when you when you like
make an honest mistake
like you say someone's name wrong or
something where it's completely honest
and accidental you will profusely
apologize because you're like so
mortified at the idea of offending
anyone yeah well not that like I would
just would never want to hurt someone's
feelings yeah by being dumb exactly
ignorant or coming off anyway like that
yeah
so that perfuse apology is true in that
sense it's if I if I don't think that
I'm wrong though I will stand my ground
I can come I can confirm that thousand
percent Julian does a really good job
apologizing though but sometimes it does
take you a minute to like get there you
know yeah like you would rather argue
for a little bit and then get there and
then apologize like you got to be sure
that you're wrong yeah but I think you
do do a really good job of Polish I
think that comes from thinking my
decision-making is pretty sharp so when
that's so when I'm faced with all the
reasons why it was it so what I'm faced
with the reality or the or the systemic
jenna breakdown of why it's not takes me
a second and it's not about like
checking an ego or anything because I
don't really I'm not a very egotistical
person at all I just think that I and
I'm not like I'm right all the time
either I just I know myself well and I
know my the way I operate well and I
feel like sometimes I'm like wait we're
we're in the in this in the process did
I go wrong here like what's what choice
did I make that was like totally [ __ ]
this up you know to me and sometimes I'm
like didn't you realize that cuz even I
can't keep up with my area sometimes
Julian's also done a good job learning
that if I start to tell him that he was
wrong that you have to pass right now
you can argue with me for about 20
minutes or you can just submit
well cuz I'll say one thing about me I'm
not gonna like pick an argument unless I
know that I'm right if there's any
chance that I'm gonna lose this argument
I'm just not gonna go down that path
yeah well in general you don't lose
arguments so but like there's I can
totally be wrong and I can totally like
but you would abandon and you would be
like yeah think of all the times when I
think that I know that I'm right and
then you're like actually an idiot
but you and far between I'd say I
wouldn't like her solar eclipse I
wouldn't go out of my way to like really
stand my ground unless I really thought
that I was right so I obviously there's
total chances that I'm completely wrong
but usually when it's like we're arguing
about something within our household and
within our relationship I'm like not
gonna pick a fight with you unless it's
like Julian there's 30 paper towels on
the counter
can you please throw them out if you
were like but babe I'm using all of them
I'm like this is when you need to stop
and just throw them the [ __ ] out but
yeah if I if I make a mistake I will
profusely apologize but Julian does do a
very good job apologize and when he is
wrong when he gets there the prosecution
would like to prevent present evidence
pulls out 30 paper towels guilty okay
not as funny Sal Power says you cheat on
veganism sometimes I think well when I
said I started being a vegan a long time
ago like ten plus years ago and that was
I was not even I was just doing it for
health reasons and I would have a cheat
meal every Sunday and to me cheat meal
meant I'm gonna eat meat and dairy which
is fine there's people that do that and
I still think that you can make an
impact from eating less animal products
if that's how you approach it but at
this point in our life and you know when
I finally went full vegan what for
something years ago now I don't see it
as cheap food you know like I just don't
I don't want to eat animal products so
that's not something that I would eat
does that make sense
I miss like the way that the cheese is
good
you know like sometimes it's hard to
find a product or something that you
want to make that like gives you that
same sensation but I certainly don't see
it as cheating because it's just it's
not something that I want to eat yeah
yeah I mean and in the most respectful
way possible when someone says to me
like how long you like how long you're
gonna do this vegan thing for or like
well you know what's this about like you
know I mean where the question is sort
of framing it as just like a fad diet or
whatever I never really take that
personally I just now that I have a
chance to answer that question I am as
ethically driven as I feel like a vegan
could be and I didn't start out like
that and I don't talk about a lot cuz
it's it's for me you know what I mean
it's like my it's it's my
decision-making and the way you know I
view things but when I started out Jenna
helped me kind of transition because I
was getting a lot of I was I was getting
sick a lot you know eating meat and she
helped me kind of learn the plant-based
diet and it was very quick that I
adapted it and I was like okay I want to
do this now I'm on the complete other
side of it where I've been doing it for
a few years and I'm cheating on the diet
isn't really an option for me it's like
I don't know how I don't know I'm trying
to compare it to something but it's like
it's it's a choice that I've made so
it's like there's no negotiating that
choice because I've already made it and
I've already stood my ground very
strongly in making that choice and I
think about things a lot when it comes
to the choice that I make to be vegan so
it never crosses my mind similar to
similar but not similar to how it
doesn't cross my mind to cheat on being
gluten free it's like the repercussions
yeah those are more physical
repercussions but I would never yeah I
would never like cheat on a vegan diet
for any reason yeah yeah all it took for
me was just watching some of that sad
stuff and it's not it's not food anymore
for me so yeah it's not it's not a
matter of cheating there's no part of me
that like wants to eat dairy cheese or
wants to eat meat so yeah no we don't we
don't cheat on our vegan diet
Nayeli Espinoza says you guys genuinely
love the dink fam
that's true we've met so many of you and
y'all are [ __ ] funny is how yeah you
know I would again bring you back to
twitch I would credit twitch with a lot
of these feelings I have after the date
them in the podcast of course yeah and
we've been at this for so long but I
would credit like this sort of forum and
twitch where we're directly interacting
with you twitch is more instant right
because we're seeing chat as we're as
we're alive but this is very similar to
because we read the comments every week
on the podcast but man like it's
something that you don't expect like to
feel so much love for the people who
support you and watch you you always
like at least starting out I always
thought like I would I would appreciate
them X amount and that would just be it
but like you guys have grown so much on
me as people and as a group of people
who choose to interact with me all the
time when you don't have to know all the
time that you interact with them it's
like they're I think that it's a group
of people that actually sort of know you
better than well for me personally that
you know the people that follow the
podcasts and the follower twitch know me
better or have a better understanding of
me as a person and people did you know
years ago when I was just making my main
channel YouTube videos know which feels
really liberating for me because it
brings you closer to them but it also
feels really accepted you know because
they support you they love you and they
show you that and you know they're there
to laugh and joke around but like I feel
much more comfortable being you know my
everyday daily self and we can go and
play video games or we can sit here and
have a conversation without the burden
of it being how outrageously
entertaining and people are still
enjoying that because they enjoy you as
a person so yeah that I think that for
me having that response from people and
then getting to know them a lot of them
by name a lot of them meeting them and
not just by their user name something
like there
y'all's real names yeah it's it's just
been really cool and we follow a lot of
you and getting to know here less is
really [ __ ] funny
we do we follow a lot of you guys but
similar to how you you know enter a new
community and you really really hope
it's a safe space for you to interact
with people and to talk to a creator or
have any sort of presence there you know
you hope it's a safe space I am the same
way with you guys I feel so lucky that
you provide us a safe space not just
other people but like you give us the
sense of like comfort and you know you
have our backs in if we're not feeling
well you wish us well or you're not
putting pressure on us to do to the
stream or whatever you don't I mean like
I feel a huge huge amount of love and
safety from you guys because of how you
act and how you are so genuine
and how they treat each other though
unlike when people come into our twitch
stream and they say we have a really
nice audience and how some of you guys
are friends with each other and I've met
through that like it's there's there's a
lot there to love and be hard not to
love so I'd say yeah we absolutely love
yeah we [ __ ] love you guys man [ __ ]
all right
Jay I'm King says I assume Jenna does
not actually have a basketball game
tomorrow how dare you how dare you it's
tomorrow it's not
we actually tossed around the idea of
going to film of a basketball highlights
video obviously if he doesn't game is
tomorrow so I would just film me
practicing yeah so it's tomorrow guys
don't worry nah man it's tomorrow um
Becca wrote well actually see this is a
username I know her name's Reston pugs
but I know her as Becca cuz she's been
around for so long and yeah she wrote a
similar question the Digg fan became a
bigger part of your lives and you ever
expect her to pretty much answer that
but yes corrected Ted absolutely
Julianne learned in his 20s not to put
silverware in the microwave
[Laughter]
come on is it true come on I learned it
in my teens to be fair though you put
out a fire in your kitchen for your mom
when you were like 10 so even if you had
done something like that you would at
least know how to put the fire out
mm-hmm I did have I told that sorry I
probably have yeah yeah yeah
don't buy teapots with rubber handles
unless you have a son who is a
firefighter who's 12 you're part of the
Illuminati probably Alicia says no beads
[Music]
like if you think they would let anyone
with a like a youtube channel have any
access to any kind of [ __ ] like
absolutely imma be in the Illuminati the
aluminum arches down below they probably
let Shane in first before anyone so they
can get him on their side it's a good
business move for them for them y'all
are really four night players in your
spare time
MUA Jordan says listen Jordan every hour
that I am NOT streaming on Twitch I am
playing fortnight on my computer and not
telling anyone about it every single
hour no remember that one person came
into chat that was that we were playing
pub G and they were like do you guys
play for nine we were like no and then
they were like we know you guys play
fortnight it's like okay got us nothing
against for tonight no but like we
recently tried it on as a lot of fun
play everyone yeah [ __ ] ton of content
there it's pretty great if Julian wasn't
with Jenna he wouldn't be vegan
Natalie Hewitt says yes and no yes
because she introduced me to it so I
credit her for that mmm and I wouldn't
have found it like I did if I was if I
was not with you
but speaking now if we were not together
now I would still be vegan
100% but let's say together as friends
I love being friends do you ends with
use the best faith Nickerson says you
rarely disagree on what you want to eat
well Julian only wants pad thai so only
only on nights where the day of the week
ends in a whi though we can usually come
up with something that we'll both eat
like we'll both be fine it's not like we
have tons of choices if we wanted to
like order we have like the same go-to
recipes and we're usually sort of in the
same mood like we have a little bit of a
weekly schedule of food so yeah I would
say that's true I also disagree yeah
cheat day if I'm like and by cheat day I
mean we don't eat the two days just
where we have like our french fries are
yeah yeah so I'll usually want Carl's
jr. has the burgers just so good [ __ ]
that's like what are the only nights of
the week though Sunday nights though is
one way of eating separately yeah cuz
it's like this is one night a week yeah
it's like your one good food and I'm
like I know what pad thai yeah but I
also feel like you and I have developed
a good barometer of when the other
person needs their favourite food yeah
so like when I win I can tell you you
need pasta I need it we make pasta and
then likewise for like Thai food you
know Asian food Zara says you guys don't
like to go out and party you much prefer
to stay home how could you tell at this
way in my life yes yeah there was a time
when I really enjoyed going out a lot
but it's not that fun for me anymore
yeah I never really was into it I really
was I really only went out because he
wanted to go would you rag his ass I was
like they're going out and I would put
on my super high shoes walk around and
just have a good time
I thought that was fun you know I didn't
drink at a bar and go dancing or
whatever we had a lot of fun it wasn't
something I would have chose to do but
like we get a lot of fun but now if we
if we do go out or we have something to
go to like it's fun
and then we won't stay very long and
we'll come home yeah and then that'll be
fun mm-hmm yeah but I don't know it's
kind of nice yeah we I think the most
trouble we get into is we'll drink and
game on a Saturday night but we're still
with all of our friends and a lot of you
guys watching live yeah enjoying
yourselves mm-hmm it's like we're at a
bar we just know everybody at the bar
and we're also in our house yeah but
it's still very social yes yeah Pedro
Julian loves locking the dogs and that
weird wine room thingy no no we almost
literally never do that there's one we
usually walk lock them in the game room
if there's like someone's coming in the
house or like you know there's occasions
when it happens when you need the dogs
to not be able to walk out the front
door well put them in the game room
where there's like a big chair and there
they all have beds and stuff to sit in
and we wouldn't put them in the wine
yeah that's where I go when when stream
puts me in timeout if I ever do
something wrong on stream they put me in
and they put me in the wine room to lay
down and think about what is a joke
24-hour locked in the wine room
challenge isn't there a bathroom one of
those going around yeah what the hell I
don't know man I haven't really watched
what I'm like I think just like you poop
and then you smell your poop all day and
then you eat with your poop
I would eat in the shower with the water
on that sounds nice I would make pasta
in the shower okay rohnke rousey says
your sleep schedule is whack and not
really a schedule at all well honestly I
think this goes for everyone on the
internet you have a sleep schedule or a
schedule in general that involves your
sleep and overtime something is just
like slapping away at it so it gets less
and less and less until it doesn't
they're called Internet hours yes it's a
phenomena that happens amongst all
people all people in there either either
it's a game we're playing or it's a
video we're trying to make or it's a
bunch of things somehow it always just
disappears
then you have to rebuild it right now
we're in a good spot though yeah over
time as you get better at it and you
need to like actually put your foot down
and like demand of your body that you're
gonna do this or not [ __ ] around and
stay up all night like yeah you fix it
but it does take some effort I think
it's because you have all the you're so
free you know like you can work whenever
you want so sleep in and like kick it
it's like very liberating cuz as younger
people we all wake up at the ass crack
of dawn to go to school every day and to
sleep in it's just like a dream come
true
you know so when you finally have the
ability to do that of course you're
gonna let some time go by where you get
to stay up late and sleep in but then
you realize wow this really isn't that
good for me or my body or my mental
anything don't you fix it back
totally so yeah we are in a good place
but we do stay up late and we do we
don't wake up at like you know the crack
of dawn yeah we don't wake up at 6:00
a.m. I wake up at like 8:30 most days
I'll probably wake up at 9:00 or 9:30
yeah
Marissa's assumptions about Julian ready
for this I'm ready I'm 15 minutes late
to everything
that's not true not true early or early
at the latest
I'm never tardy I don't ever I mean I
would say like I think she's saying that
cuz like I'm always late for stream and
stream I'm notoriously late for like
we'll say it's 7:00 at 7:30 30 it's 8:00
but as far as in person like I have a if
I have a lunch meeting a meeting if I
especially was across town I'm gonna
leave embarrassingly early just in case
there's a terrible traffic jam and I
still have time to get there cuz I don't
I I hate people
I [ __ ] hate being late yeah he's
never late and I get a normal with
streams sometimes we might be late for a
stream because the dogs are fighting and
won't finish their stream is different I
would admit I'm normally late to stream
but other things yeah I like can't allow
myself to be late to you like to worse
what they have roasted you like to wear
clothes that are one size smaller than
you should wear who is that to me rude
wait what when did no get away from the
keyboard and the mixer my god
he's our audio engineer
not he's gonna drool on the [ __ ]
Apollo in short it is this shirt too
tight Marissa I don't this is a large am
I an XL person should I switch to XL
I mean you wear whatever you want but I
don't think your clothes are too small
um maybe I should look into Excel we'll
just we'll test it up okay take a bunch
of pictures and you send them to Marissa
don't try on clothes for guys okay you
stitch fix stitch fix will get you
whatever clothes you want at the size
that you should be wearing unlike me
check it out Tim roasted yourself you're
very routine oriented but don't want to
admit it I am I love and crave routine
you are you are a creature of habit I
feel like I have a routine too though I
forced you to make a schedule and tell
me everything that you're doing there
like within within Julian things I have
a routine I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is but okay but I do that's all that
matters like that I understand my
routine yet no one else it's like it's
like hieroglyphs no one should be able
to read or understand my routine as long
as I can understand oh that's the area
code my like week is always the same
everything needs to be the same for me
and if something new is gonna come in I
need to like mentally prepare myself for
it and like decide whether or not I do
it mentally physically or emotionally
and if there's any change to it I don't
like it you know yeah unless I have
enough time to prepare for that but like
even you know when we take on new stuff
like I need to decide whether or not I
can fit it in and if I can then I commit
to it until forever forever literally
until someone else stops it exactly but
that's why I won't like add something
new in unless I'm like yes I commit to
doing this until forever otherwise I
need to reevaluate this fitting in this
place or this yeah whatever yeah so my
schedule is always pretty much the same
and I do like routine I like routine too
but like my own routine yeah I know your
routine but you sound to us a little
while you've trained me to make that
ledger
to other people well cuz he'll just do
this thing where he's like yeah I'm
gonna go do this and then I'm gonna go
do that and then I'm gonna do this and
I'm like how did you just add seven
things into the day like what the hell
carpe diem you know just like gotta do
it lastly you don't actually know how to
tie your shoes I do know how to tie my
shoes
but lower case B comma I often pre tie
my shoes and then slip on my shoes so
like all my Adidas like my ultra boost I
don't tie those shoes cuz they're
already tied
I don't read tie them I like really
tightly double knot them and then just
slip them on and off so now they're like
slip-on shoes with my converse I prefer
them untied I like to walk around with
them untied that's wild no it's not I
think it provides more freedom oh boy
and it has a different look if you tie
up your converse or your vans or what
did I say commerce I meant bands if you
tie up your vans or converse granese
sneaker like that
you look really straight-laced and like
I'm not about that I'm just chillin oh
you're not a regular dad you're a cool
that cool dad oh my laces are untied
I should just get some Crocs I have
Crocs no I don't currently I don't I
have [ __ ] I just got those boots that
you have yeah I got her gardening boots
really like them or dining that's
whatever they're just shoes all right
well there it is those are your
assumptions about us sir I will say
those were all for the most part very
kind so thanks for that yell to the
people we chose thank you there were
some that the only one you were saying
like I was like are all of them like are
any of them like real nasty some of them
were just like shots at us like what
like someone was just like y'all are
rich and you enjoy being rich oh [ __ ]
okay
oh [ __ ] I don't know what kind of
discussion you wants to have about this
tweet but it's exactly this is the
discussion just like us looking at each
other I don't know but there was a
couple were like Julian is just like
calling me childish and like that kind
of thing but like I guess that's kind of
a
so that's fine and I deserve it
probably but you're a wonderful friend
your I would want you to be there with
me alongside me as a friend only through
anything fake and thin but as a friend
and we have to sleep in separate beds
cause we're friends yeah like I Love
Lucy we sleep in two twin beds next to
each other except we're friends though I
don't love Lucy I'm friends with Lucy
okay I get it cool mm-hmm so we'll put a
divider between the beds you don't look
at me okay I'm friends with you but also
just like turn around
okay all right in general okay all right
can we all look how about we all agree
that where we're gonna put the friends
joke in the friend zone and just keep it
there well after you just said friends
to 30 times you've only made it stronger
get it out of your system otherwise it's
just gonna keep up the joke
yes I've heard it from my system it's
gone okay friend no yeah it's gone you
can't do that okay friend hey lover
[Laughter]
sweet pie sweetie pie sweet pea sweetie
pee
sweetie pees fine sweetie pee hey lover
a case we TP a cage Anna welfare is such
a weird like oh that's Oh lover
[Laughter]
well we're just gonna go do lover things
like eat dinner together while we look
each other in the hold hands with both
hands so we just eat with our mouths
like it's not that Brent Ben Stiller
movie what is that one I can't remember
I'm paying Polly
no they just get married and then they
go to Meet the Fockers meet the parents
no they go on their honeymoon oh and he
gets cut wait yeah he does that's Along
Came Polly at the beginning of a long
game long Came Polly yeah
no that's what we're jennifer aniston
isn't it and she is a ferret yeah but
the reason he's heartbroken and falls
into her arms is because he was
heartbroken and cooked on vacation I
think I don't think that's right I think
I'm money I'm thinking of I think I'm
right I think I'm right Ben Stiller goes
on vacation and the girl he's with
cheats on him with the guy who runs the
boat right on that boat isn't that
that's all I came following Along Came
Polly is the woman where that's Jennifer
innocent note selma Blair or something
is the other but there are two girls
there are no no we're thinking of there
are two girls what yes yeah he is still
there is it you know long camp Olly
I don't know that is he oh he is okay
you're right
there's a whole first half of the movie
that you're thinking that you're missing
oh no no no no I'm thinking of a
different movie it's a long game Paula
I'm sure everyone is just screaming the
right name of the movie right now no
it's not oh wait why are we talking
about this again oh because they're
holding hands while they're eating what
are you talking about forgetting sarah
marshall because that's not Ben Stiller
can we just can we make a bet right now
if I'm right what do I get
all right everyone just s in chat for
Jenna
cuz I'm right here there's no way it's
not a long game boy there's no way it's
not a long game Poli no it's the
Heartbreak Kid that's the one I'm
thinking of
it's not Along Came Polly I've never
seen it are you sure the Heartbreak Kid
yeah this was the movie poster never
seen that girl I was starting Malin
Akerman
[ __ ] I was wrong yeah she's like I like
when we hold hands when we eat
so honey she's like eating with her
right hand and he's like trying to eat
his left hand or whatever he's like [ __ ]
we're naughty
we're not even just doing the whole both
hands and just like scarf it down man
picks the follow promise damn I thought
I was right on that one no back to the
drawing board I guess you guys just have
to be involved huh they like know when
the podcast is over and they start just
like climbing they also know when the
stream is over they know our schedule
better than we do yet dogs have very
strong body clock well thank you guys
for hanging out with us and listening to
the podcast this week we will be back
next week for another one and we'll be
on stream all week long happy Airy
season this week hope you guys are
getting your tornadoes going spinning
fast but we appreciate you and thank you
for sending in your assumptions help you
guys have a good week bye
[Music]
you
[Music]